I realize that made a slight error in
the last video when I talk about the
population and the sample mean so I will
rewrite the equations I realize I made a
slight notational error and it might
have confused a little bit so just to
review a little bit it never hurts the
mean of a population once again that's
mu the mean of a population is equal to
you take the sum of each of the data
points so you take the sum that's that
big Sigma's for of each of the data
points so X sub I had written X sub n
before and if you review that last video
you can see why it might be a little
confusing and you start with the first
data point so I is equal to 1 you start
with the first data point and you take
the sum all the way to the nth data
point right where we have a big capital
n where n is a total number of elements
in the population and then you divide
that by n so that's another way of
writing X sub 1 plus X sub 2 plus and
you just keep adding bum-bum-bum however
many there are X sub N and then you
divide that by n and I think that's what
you're familiar with is just the
arithmetic mean and or the average you
just add up all of the elements and you
divide by the total number of elements
there are that's just a fancy way of
writing that and then the sample mean is
essentially the same thing although use
slightly different notation the sample
mean is written as X with a line over it
and that's equal to once again the sum
of the elements in the sample right and
then you have there's a slight
notational difference you start at the
first element in the sample and you go
to the number of elements in the sample
and that's why they use that lowercase n
there are big n elements in the whole
population and if you took some subset
of that you know we're assuming that n
is less small n is less than or equal to
big n and anyway you divide that by the
total number of elements in the
population in the sample so once again
this would be you know x1 plus x2 plus
dun-dun-dun plus X lowercase n divided
by lowercase n these are essentially the
same thing if your sample was the entire
population then these ends would be
equal to each other and these numbers
would be equal to each other but just
the notation
difference if you ever see this you know
you're dealing with the sample here you
know you're dealing with the entire
population and similarly big an entire
population small in the sample fair
enough I think we're now ready to learn
a little bit about measures of
dispersion so the mean and the mode and
the median that we covered in the first
video in this playlist we're all ways of
measuring the central tendency of a data
set or kind of picking a number that is
most representative of all of the
numbers but we lose a lot of information
we don't know whether all of the numbers
in the data set are close to that number
close to the mean or maybe they're all
really far away from the mean and that's
why we want to come up with measures of
dispersion dispersion and let me tell
you let me show you what I mean so let's
say I have one set and let's say I don't
know let's say it is a 2 a 2 and a 3 and
a 3 let's say this is a population let's
just deal with population population
means and population dispersions for now
so what's the mean here the mean here is
going to be 2 plus 2 Plus 3 plus 3 all
of that all of that over 4 and what is
that that's equal to 2 and a half right
4 plus 6 divided by 4 right that's equal
to 2.5 fair enough fair enough now what
if we had this what if we had the
numbers I don't know 0 0 & 5 & 5 so
these are the numbers in the set up with
commas just you know these are separate
numbers what's the mean here well the
mean here and let's say this is the
population that we're sampling but this
isn't a sample this is the entire
population and you'll see why I'm making
a distinction later so it'll be 0 plus 0
plus 5 plus 5 well that's 10 divided by
4 is equal to 2.5 so the arithmetic mean
of both of these populations are the
same number they're both 2.5 right but
you see that these these sets are kind
of they're different here all of the
numbers are pretty close to 2.5
right well here sure they're there mean
their arithmetic mean is 2.5 but they're
further away from 2.5 or the distances
of each of these numbers each of the
data each of the the numbers in the set
their distance from the mean is further
so you can kind of view them that
they're more dispersed the further away
from the mean or another way you can
think of it is the mean although it is
it does measure its central tendency it
doesn't it's not quite as indicative of
all the numbers the numbers are much
further away from the mean on average so
how do you measure that
well you measure that with the variance
and this is something I found and even
in my own you know it seems complicated
when you first look at it and most
statistics textbooks use fairly complex
notations but the idea is almost as
straightforward as the arithmetic mean
so what they'll do is they'll write you
know the variance and they'll write it
as this letter Sigma this Greek letter I
put the top part too long let me
actually undo that I don't want you to
spend the rest of your life writing with
a big top part they write it as Sigma
squared and we'll talk about it in a few
seconds about why it's written is you
know why why don't they just write V for
variance why do they write you know this
weird letter squared I'll talk talk
we'll talk about in a second but the
variance of a population is defined and
once again these are just human derived
constructs of time to get our hint or
our minds around data being able to
describe a set of data without having to
list all the numbers and in being able
to kind of understand what what that
data might represent what can represent
that data so what you do is you take the
sum you take the sum and you start with
each all of the points in the population
but instead of taking the sum of the
points you take each point X sub I and
you subtract from that and actually
doesn't matter if you subtract from that
or you subtract that from the mean the
population mean and then you square it
so what is this this is the distance
between each number and the mean and
then when you square it becomes a
positive number so you can kind of view
it as just so you know the squared
absolute distance between each number
and the mean of that set and then you
take the average of all of those
and you divide that by n now that might
seem like a very complicated notion but
let's let's calculate it for these two
data sets so here let me rewrite that
first data set it's two two three and
three so what is let me actually let me
write it this way I think this will this
will help explain it to for you a little
bit better so if I wrote I I 1 I 2 I 3 I
4 that's I then X sub I it's kind of
arbitrary it's just you know this is
saying the first term the second term
the third term I could have had this in
any order doesn't matter you know maybe
this was the first term and this is a
second and this is the third it doesn't
matter because I'm just going to add
them all up and then divide them so it
doesn't matter what order we do it but
anyway X sub 1 X sub 1 is X sub 1 is
equal to 2 X sub 2 is equal to 2 X sub 3
is equal to 3 I'll stop writing this
equal thing X sub 4 is equal to 4 right
what's the mean well we figured out the
mean up here we just took these numbers
and added them and divided by 4 the mean
is 2.5 the mean is 2.5 so what is X sub
I minus the mean right we're slowly
building up to this equation what is X
sub I minus the mean well 2 minus 2.5
that's minus 0.5 2 minus 2.5 that's once
again minus 0.5 3 minus 2 point five
that's 0.5 3 minus 2 point 5 that's 0.5
fair enough now this equation they want
us to square this so X sub I minus the
mean squared and and that has well
there's several other properties we'll
talk about later but the most important
thing that the squaring does and the
absolute value could have done it as
well but the squaring makes all of these
positives so minus 0.5 squared is
positive 0.25 this is positive 0.25 plus
0.5 squared is also positive 0.25
and this is positive 0.25 and so what is
so if we wanted to know the sum from I
is equal to 1 to 4 of X sub I minus the
mean which is 2.5 squared this is equal
to what the sum of all of these numbers
this is just saying sum all of these so
sum all of these 0.25 so that's equal to
1 but this isn't the variance yet the
variance is this thing let's look at the
original formula the variance is this
thing divided by the total number of
numbers you have right so you take this
and then you so the variance is equal to
this thing divided by the total number
of numbers which is 4 which is equal to
0.25 and you see I mean here the
distance from every number square the
distance from every number to the mean
squared was 0.25 so the average of all
of these which is essentially what the
variance is the average was also 0.25
and I'll do another example where these
are different the other example in this
video actually they're not different but
you see here the average squared
distance from the mean and that first
dataset is 0.25 and here what's the
average squared distance from the mean
so let's see this is how far from the
mean it is so let's say X let me write X
sub I and then X sub I minus the mean
and this for this popular so X sub I
there's zero there's zero there's a 5
and a 5 right this is the first term X
sub 1 X sub X sub 1 this is X sub 2 and
so forth and then each of these numbers
minus means 0 minus 2 plus minus 2 point
5 0 minus 2 point 5 right this could be
2 point 5 all right that's the mean it's
minus 2 point 5 five minus two point
five is two point five five minus two
point five is two point five now if you
took X sub I minus the mean squared two
point five squared is what six point two
five it becomes positive so six point
two five that's the same thing six point
two five that's already positive so six
point two five
6.25 and so the variance is the sum of
all of these divided by the total number
of numbers there are right so we take
the sum of all so since the average of
these and that's pretty easy to
calculate if you took if you added all
of these up and divided by four you're
going to get six point two five so the
variance of this population is six point
two five so there you have it you have
two data sets where their means are the
same but the variance of this data set
is equal to we figured out was 0.25
while the variance while the variance of
this data set is equal to six point two
five it's hard right now to have an
intuition of what this you know what you
know how does the six relate to the
point two five but you know that this is
a larger number this is a much larger
number then this is which tells you just
kind of an intuitive feel that the
numbers in this set are on average much
further away from the mean than the
numbers in this data set anyway I'm out
of time I'll see in the next video and
we'll talk a little bit about this and
we'll talk and we'll move into the
standard deviation and then what happens
if you take these of a sample instead of
a population everything we're doing here
we're taking the mean and the variance
of every number in the data set later
we'll do it for the sample see you soon